in the very first line of the script -
in Bruges the writer and director Martin
McDonagh describes this medieval town
with its gothic churches and narrow
canals as otherworldly this is our first
hint to the kind of presence that Bruges
will impose on the characters of this
morality tale about to Irish hitmen the
hitmen in question are Ken a seasoned
pro and Ray his brash juvenile young
partner who's just [__] up his very
first job by accidentally killing an
innocent child their boss has sent them
both to Bruges to hide out and await
judgment in this way these two events
the crime and the judgement bookend the
film for the duration were stuck with
ken and Ray in purgatory for McDonagh
Bruges as purgatory purgatory as Bruges
is the perfect really the only kind of
place for this story to be staged like
much of his previous work in the theater
McDonough is concerned with
investigating morality in a postmodern
world a world that finds it exceedingly
difficult to invoke traditional measures
of right wrong don't bother
indeed is usually those characters with
rigid inflexible moralities that
McDonough portrays as the cruelest of
all and they also happen to be the ones
who like to talk about it the most if
I'll killed a little kid accidentally or
otherwise I wouldn't have thought twice
or to kill myself on the [__] spot on
the [__] spot to stop the gun in my
mouth on the [__] spot in this movie
that character is the boss Harry who's
code of honor among thieves enacts a
morality of mechanical cause and effect
so na hoona looking at that smile it's
obvious that harry takes pride in this
code his devotion to it is annealed even
religious and at the end of the film
when he himself triggers this mechanism
his own action appears to him merely as
an observation of a force it's beyond
him I say now it's fitting that harry
has these qualities because as he's the
one who sends kenan ray into purgatory
and decides their judgment he works as a
parallel for another kind of inflexible
morality one that saturates Bruges the
city and in Bruges the film Catholic
imagery is everywhere here indeed it's
hard to imagine a town more traditional
in this respect Bruges is one of the
best preserved medieval cities in the
world its existence even some of its
architecture dating back to the 12th
century in one Church there is even a
file that contains a cloth with the
blood of Jesus himself or so some belief
kenan ray visited this church in the
film but the christian symbolism is even
more apparent in a later scene when the
hitmen visit a local museum McDonough
puts three critical scenes back-to-back
here to maximize their resonance against
each other and it's worth it to look at
all three first we have the flashback of
Ray's botched murder which it's not
insignificant to note is the murder of a
Catholic priest the boy he accidentally
shoots is holding in his hand a paper
that lists his sins being moody being
bad at maths and being said and though
these are obviously not punishable
they're all applicable to
he's moody and sad throughout the film
and in a darkly comic way matching this
films very black humor he should have
killed one person instead of two which
some would call being bad at maths but
just introducing the idea of religious
sin will be important for the following
two scenes after this we find ray and
Ken in the groaning Museum looking at
three paintings the first is death and
the miser by Jan provost described in
the script as the skeletal Death come to
collect his due the second is the
judgment of Cambyses by gerard de vide
which depicts the flaying alive of an
ancient persian judge who accepted
bribes and the third painting is the
most famous hieronymus Bosch's triptych
painting the Last Judgement which
depicts Jesus Christ presiding over a
bunch of monstrous demons punishing the
wicked in various gruesome ways the
things you're taught as a child in every
level I think the lesson of these
paintings of punishment and retribution
the lessons of Catholicism for those who
were raised in that tradition never
really leave you entirely and the same
is true for Western society collectively
negotiating the transition from a world
founded on divine morality to one built
by human morality the former lingers
like being stuck in a city where the
monuments of history tower all around
you because the choices I made and the
course that I put into action the little
boy isn't here anymore I didn't have a
be here again
I mean here in the world not here in bed
though these final lines feel like a bit
of a comic throwaway I think they're
actually central to McDonough's message
in all of his work McDonough has
characters repeat their phrases multiple
times I go the way Jesus the way hey the
way or incessantly qualify what they say
besides being funny and lending rhythm
to the work McDonagh I think is trying
to point out the fact that morality in
the new world is discursive which is to
say that it happens in language for this
reason McDonough frequently encourages
us to consider the language of his film
the discourse of the script it's not a
coincidence that in Bruges takes place
on the fringes of a film set our fennel
imagines and that the film in question
is a remake of Nicolas Roeg's don't look
now another movie about a city Venice
that imposes a strong influence on its
characters of course it's not quite a
remake it's a best issue of Nicolas
Roeg's don't look now not a best teacher
but a homage is too strong another bet
again we have characters searching for
the right word in this way McDonough
forces us to analyze the work he's
written because that's what this kind of
new morality requires you need to weigh
up all your options but your conscious
decide can we all have to be the authors
of our own morality as Ray's stumbles
through the film set at the end people
buy characters out of Bosh's Last
Judgement pursued by the inflexible
morality of Harry he's shot and is
pulled away on the stretcher in his
voiceover he says narrating really hoped
which is grammatically a very strange
thing to say hoped is in the past tense
while wouldn't is in the future tense
where exactly is this narration coming
from from heaven or the afterlife or
Israel I've for calling the events from
sometime in the future the film leaves
it ambiguous which of course means that
we have to decide Martin McDonagh is
trying to show us that whether it comes
to language or purgatory or morality or
bruges ray and the film and all the rest
of us never
get to leave
oh hey everybody thanks for watching and
thank you to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video
people Squarespace are awesome for
helping to fund this channel keep it
going help me make bigger and better
projects and they're also awesome for
not interfering in the content which is
really important and really cool so just
like you guys who are pledging on
patreon they're supporting me and
helping helping this continue you can go
to squarespace.com and get a free domain
name if you sign up for a year they do
really great professional sleek-looking
websites if you don't know you don't
need to know coding or anything to make
it happen and if you go to Squarespace
comm and use the offer code nerdwriter
you can get 10% off your first purchase
so that's really cool too
Squarespace you should so thanks guys so
much I'll see you next Wednesday